well something is brewing in southern
nevada over the past decade henderson
and las vegas
have become home to craft breweries
which many have opened in just the last
few years
so this recent surge is really catching
the eyes of locals and tourists and now
the city of las vegas
which is committed to making itself the
next beer capital
kate houston took her very own brewery
tour across the valley to see
how these businesses are pouring new
life into southern nevada one pint at a
time
we're getting a lot more locals coming
down to visit we're getting a lot more
people feeling it safer down here to
come and actually enjoy the breweries
and enjoy the new businesses
scott seals works for abel baker brewing
which opened nearly two years ago
and is known for its atomic duck logo
and the widely distributed ipa
of the same name we were kind of the
beginning of this boom
that was down here seals says craft
breweries bring a different feel
and crowd to the downtown las vegas area
every generation has its uh
its likes and we're seeing a lot more
people look towards breweries as opposed
to that nightclub scene now which i
absolutely love
while new breweries are opening up left
and right nevada is still behind
ranking 39th in the nation we're working
really hard
quadruple time to bring it up to
the national trend windy forest with
nevada craft brewers association and
craft house brewery
says beer tourism is on the rise and
hopes las vegas
can be a top viewer destination those
tourists who are coming back to las
vegas
are probably going to be looking for
something a little bit different as well
a little something more unique and
personal and that's what craft breweries
can offer this momentum is now being
pushed further by the city of las vegas
with an incentive package to bring even
more breweries to the recently
established brewery row
this brewery boom is wide reaching and
bringing new opportunities to north las
vegas
construction is really underway amanda
pion is in the process of opening north
fifth brewing
i feel like our location is great
because we do have all the businesses
and a lot of these
workers have come to us as soon as they
saw the sign and we're like oh my gosh
i get to have craft beer after work or
even just to take it home just to have
that option close by
kion hopes to open shop by the end of
the year it's not just beer
you know it's not just something that
you can drink to have a good time but
you get so many different flavors
and that's one great thing about even
though the industry is growing so much
everybody can do their own thing and you
get a little bit of
a little bit of everything from
everybody kate houston 8 news now